can we talk a little bit about freedom
what what does it mean to you having had
we talked about love in that same way
about freedom
having sort of discovered it later in
life
what does it mean to you i think
every day i get new definition of
freedom
it is it's a never-ending journey
having this relationship with being free
and what it means to be a freeway
i think i think
uh you definitely can live life without
being free
and also happy life too i saw a lot of
nursing
elites were were fed and have power but
didn't have freedom or
very happy in a way happier than the
people that i found in eo
were like investment bankers and
consultants in manhattan
and seventy percent of them go like talk
therapists
i was very confused i remember writing
my book in new york
like my editor was saying you mean you
know like you're traumatized
you need to go talk to therapists and
it's like what is therapy right
what is trauma because in north korea
they don't have word for stress or
trauma because
how can you be stressed in the socialist
paradise so they don't let you be
knowing what that is yes so and then
they were like
yeah hearing people having problems go
talk to therapists
and i was like like how much is it
actually like 200
per hour and it's a discounted rate too
it's like no thank you
[Laughter]
you know i was like you know and we know
that freedom
comes with responsibility and
in a way it's not that easy to be free
thinking for yourself constantly like
when you
in a way i understand like let's give
government every power we have
let them decide what education that i
get let them decide where i live like
you know
let someone figure that out for me and
that's how north korea began
hoping the government gonna represent my
own interest
believing that they were good and with
that
benefit of that and good faith you began
the nightmare right
yeah so freedom is not like a gay way to
be happy at all
in a way it can make life a lot more
complex but then it's fun
isn't it you start being for yourself
you start making mistakes
and it's so fun to be free even though
you can be suffering way more
than the people who are not free the
thing about freedom is
when you have freedom you also have the
responsibility for your actions and that
could be a huge burden
yeah because um
if you succeed it's you but if you
fail it's you yeah and uh if you do
horrible things it's you if you don't do
something for example if you don't help
people in north korea it's you yeah and
that's a huge burden
yeah and living with that burden
is a kind of suffering i mean there's
some aspect in which freedom is
suffering
it is suffering because life is
suffering and then the freedom
is uh you as an individual fully
living through that
you